PRESIDENT TRUMP AND DEMOCRATS
HAD TO COLLIDE ON TWO KEY
ISSUES.
THE BORDER WALL AND OBAMACARE.
FIRST, WITH A POTENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN LOOMING,
WHITE HOUSE AND DEMOCRATS
CONTINUE TO CLASH OVER BORDER
SPENDING.
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER CLAIMING
THERE IS NO WAY LAWMAKERS WILL
GREEN LIGHT FUNDING FOR THE
WALL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE NOT THE
VOTES FOR THE WALL IN THE HOUSE
OR THE SENATE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO GET THE WALL
IN ANY FORM.
EVEN THE HOUSE, WHICH IS A
MAJORITY REPUBLICAN, THEY DON'T
HAVE THE VOTES FOR HIS
$5 BILLION WALL PLAN.
>> Dana: WHITE HOUSE ADVISOR
STEPHEN MILLER SAYS THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO BLINK
ON THE ISSUE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO WHATEVER
IS NECESSARY TO BUILD THE BORDER
WALL TO STOP THIS ONGOING CRISIS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS A SIMPLE
CHOICE.
THEY CAN EITHER CHOOSE TO FIGHT
FOR AMERICA'S WORKING CLASS OR
PROMOTE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
YOU CAN'T DO BOTH.
>> Dana: ALSO PRESIDENT TRUMP
READY TO REPLACE OBAMACARE AFTER
A FEDERAL JUDGE RULED IT TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
DEMOCRATS ALREADY LINING UP TO
CHALLENGE THE DECISION.
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND OTHER TOP
DEMOCRATS ARE VOWING TO FIGHT
WHILE OTHERS ARE USING IT TO
PUSH FOR UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE,
WHICH WE WILL PROBABLY HEAR A
LOT ABOUT.
CAN WE CALL UP THE PRESIDENT'S
TWEET ABOUT THE BORDER.
I WILL PROVIDE THAT TO THE
VIEWER.
HE SAID:
"ANYTIME YOU HEAR A DEMOCRAT
SAYING THAT YOU CAN HAVE GOOD
BORDER SECURITY WITHOUT A WALL,
WRITE THEM OFF AS JUST ANOTHER
POLITICIAN FOLLOWING THE PARTY
LINE.
TIME FOR US TO SAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR AND HAVE, AT THE
SAME TIME, FAR GREATER SAFETY
AND CONTROL!"
GREG.
>> Greg: BORDER WAS SPELLED
CORRECTLY IN THAT TWEET.
I CAN SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
COMBINE THE BORDER WALL AND
OBAMACARE.
IF YOU BUILD THE WALL, YOU GET
FREE HEALTH CARE.
THAT'S WHY I AM 2020 FOR
EVERYBODY.
WHAT I FIND INTERESTING.
NO ONE LIKES THAT IDEA?
>> Dana: HOW IS THAT GOING TO
WORK?
>> Greg: MEXICO BUILDS A WALL
AND GETS FREE HEALTH CARE.
THE IRONY OF THIS, I AM
PUNCH-DRUNK.
GOVERNMENT IS THE ANSWER FOR
EVERYTHING FOR DEMOCRATS.
IT'S THE ANSWER RIGHT NOW FOR
HEALTH CARE.
OBAMACARE IS GOVERNMENT.
IT'S FOR EVERYTHING EXCEPT THE
WALL.
THAT'S WHERE THE GOVERNMENT
HAPPILY ABDICATES THE     THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND SAYS WE WANT
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT WHICH
MAKES NO SENSE AT ALL.
IF YOU SAY THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
TAKE OVER HEALTH CARE, WHY DON'T
YOU DO THE WALL AS WELL?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
>> Dana: JESSE, A POLL IN THE
"USA TODAY" POLL, I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING.
IT'S TRUE THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS OPPOSE A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN BUT IT WAS ONLY 4%.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE COUNTRY
HAS A STOMACH FOR THE SHUTDOWN.
SO YOU CAN'T GO TO THE NATIONAL
PARKS, WHO CARES?
IN THE SPIRIT OF GREG'S
BIPARTISANSHIP, I THINK TRUMP
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD WHEN HE
SAID PUT SOLAR PANELS ON THE
WALL TO GET THE DEMOCRATS TO
VOTE FOR IT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WANTS THE
OWNERSHIP OF THE SHUTDOWN.
I DON'T THINK HE NECESSARILY
NEEDS TO TAKE THAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE WOULD OWN THE SHUTDOWN.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THIS PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED BY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO PROVIDE
BORDER SECURITY, HE HAS A
MANDATE TO BUILD THE WALL,
CURRENTLY HE STILL HAS CONTROL
OVER THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
IF THEY SEND UP TO THE SENATE
WHILE FUNDING AT 5 BILLION IN A
BUDGET, THEN IT'S THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE THE
INTERCHANGE THE INTRANSIGENT
ONES AND SHOULD OWN THE
SHUTDOWN.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS
BEING FRAMED AS DONALD TRUMP'S
FAULT.
LOOK AT THE SPENDING.
HE ONLY WANTS 3.5 BILLION MORE
IN A $4 TRILLION BUDGET.
I RAN THE NUMBERS, DANA.
THAT'S .075%.
LESS THAN ONE-TENTH OF A
PERCENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE FIGHTING
OVER.
IT'S NOT ABOUT SECURITY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PRINCIPLES.
IT'S JUST ABOUT POLITICS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAND THE
PRESIDENT A VICTORY.
THE OTHER REASON IS THEY KNOW
WALL'S WORK.
THEY DON'T WANT TO LEAVE A
LASTING REMINDER THAT TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT.
FOR EVERYBODY TO SEE FOR
GENERATIONS.
>> Greg: THE TRUMP WALL.
>> Jesse: EXACTLY.
>> Dana: JUAN, DO YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE SHUTDOWN
POSSIBILITIES OR OBAMACARE OR DO
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
INNOVATIVE AND COMBINED THE TWO.
>> Juan: I WAS OVERWHELMED BY
PEANUT BUTTER AND JELLY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I THINK YOU
ARE JUST MAKING A SPOOF OUT OF
THIS.
IT'S KIND OF CRAZY.
I MEAN, YOU SAID WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE.
I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING.
WHAT SCHUMER SAID IS RIGHT.
HE HAS THE HOUSE AND HE HAS
SENATE BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
VOTES.
>> Jesse: I DON'T BELIEVE
SCHUMER.
>> Juan: WHY DOESN'T THE
HOUSEBOAT?
>> Jesse: THEY WILL.
THEY ARE WAITING FOR CRUNCH
TIME.
>> Juan: CRUNCH TIME IS GOING
TO COME.
HALF THE PEOPLE WILL BE THERE.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD SITUATION FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
JESSE, WHILE YOU SAY HEY, YOU
THINK THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
LET'S GO TO THE VIDEOTAPE.
>> Jesse: HE DID IT.
I AGREE.
>> Juan: MITCH MCCONNELL,
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER, HAS
ALREADY SAID HE DOESN'T WANT
THIS.
HE'S TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT TO BUCK
THE PRESIDENT.
HE WANTS TO STAY LOYAL TO THE
PRESIDENT.
HE IS ON RECORD AS SAYING HE
WANTS TRUMP'S SUPPORT WHEN HE'S
UP FOR REELECTION NEXT YEAR.
>> Jesse: AND HE WILL GET IT.
>> Juan: BUT NO ONE IN THE
SENATE TAKES THIS SERIOUSLY.
WHAT YOU HEARD FROM JOHN CORNYN
WHEN HE SAW TRUMP TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE COMING
SHUTDOWN, OH, MY GOD.
WHAT DID HE DO?
>> Jesse: THE BUCK STOPS HERE.
I GUESS HE STOLE IT FROM TRUMAN.
>> Dana: THERE WAS PRESSURE
WITH REPUBLICAN SAYING DON'T SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO SHUTDOWN THE
GOVERNMENT BEFORE THE MIDTERMS
BUT NOW THE MIDTERMS ARE OVER.
REPUBLICANS LOST A LOT OF SEATS
IN THE HOUSE.
NOW THAT POLITICAL PRESSURE
ISN'T THERE.
THIS SHUTDOWN COULD LAST A
WHILE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S TRUE AND I
THINK HE'S TAKING CREDIT FOR THE
SHUTDOWN BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
PROVE THAT HE HAS SOME GUTS.
REPUBLICANS ARE ALWAYS SUCH A
BUNCH OF SCAREDY CATS.
DEMOCRATS WON'T RUN WITH THIS
LANGUAGE ABOUT A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN, THEY SCARE THE HECK
OUT OF EVERYBODY.
THEY DON'T TELL YOU THAT YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY CHECKS ARE STILL
GOING TO GO OUT.
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID, THE
MILITARY, THE POST OFFICE IS
GOING TO STAY OPEN.
BUT THEY MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE IT'S
ARMAGEDDON.
TRUMP IS SAYING IF I HAVE TO
SHUT DOWN, THIS PARTIAL SHUTDOWN
OF THE GOVERNMENT, LIKE YOU SAID
MAYBE PARKS WON'T STAY OPEN.
BUT I'M GOING TO DO IT BECAUSE
THE ISSUE OF BORDER SECURITY IS
THAT IMPORTANT.
THIS IS THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
GOING ON AT THE BORDER AND NO
OTHER REPUBLICAN AS THE GUTS TO
SAM EITHER GOING TO GET IT DONE
OR WILL DO A PARTIAL SHUTDOWN TO
SHOW THAT I'M NOT KIDDING.
HE'S WILLING TO DO IT AND I
COMMEND HIM FOR THAT.
I THINK THAT IT SHOWS THESE TWO
ISSUES, OBAMACARE AND THE
BORDER, I THINK IT SHOWED SUCH A
VAST DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY LEFT AND RIGHT VIEW THE
WORLD THAT ONE TRUMP WAS
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THEM COMING
TOGETHER AND SAYING ON THESE
ISSUES, I HAVE A LOT OF
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS.
I THINK WE CAN SIT AT A TABLE.
I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
FREE-MARKET HEALTH CARE AND ON
THE OTHER SIDE, YOU'VE GOT
SOMETHING AS DRASTIC AS MEDICARE
FOR ALL, THAT'S GOVERNMENT RUN
HEALTH CARE VERSUS INDIVIDUALS
RUNNING THEIR OWN HEALTH CARE
MAKING THEIR OWN DECISIONS.
THOSE THINGS ARE WORLDS AND
WORLDS APART.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU MEET IN THE
MIDDLE.
>> Greg: WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS BEFORE.
WE ARE LIVING IN THE PRISON OF
TWO IDEAS.
BOTH -- YOU'RE TALKING
HEALTH CARE AND THE WALL, THEY
ARE AT THE PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
THE REPUBLICANS LIKE ORDER AND
DEMOCRATS LIKE COMPASSION.
THEY THINK THESE CAN'T BE
COMBINED.
YOU ARE IN A PRISON OF TWO
IDEAS.
YOU LOOK AT OBAMACARE.
REPUBLICANS SAY FREE-MARKET
SOLUTION.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY COMPASSION,
GOVERNMENT-CENTERED SOLUTIONS.
NO ONE BELIEVES THEY CAN COME
TOGETHER, SO YOU'RE IN A PRISON
OF TWO IDEAS.
IN FACT, THERE'S A SOLUTION IN
THE MIDDLE FOR EACH ONE OF THESE
THINGS.
IT'S GOING -- I THINK FOR ALL OF
US THAT'S GOING TO BE SOLVED BY
TECHNOLOGY.
>> Jesse: I HAVE ALWAYS SAID
THE WALL IS COMPASSIONATE.
IT'S COMPASSIONATE TO THE
AMERICAN WORKER AND ALWAYS
PEOPLE COMING UP FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO RISK.
>> Juan: IT'S LIKE A BRICK.
IT'S A BRICK HOUSE UP THERE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
I DON'T --
>> Juan: I MUST SAY WAIT A
SECOND.
REPUBLICANS HAD BEEN IN CHARGE,
GREG, AND THEY HADN'T BEEN ABLE
TO REPEAL AND REPLACE OBAMACARE.
OBAMACARE IS NOW, THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S SO POPULAR.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE SOMETHING
HAS BEEN HANGING AROUND TO THE
POINT WHERE PEOPLE THINK OH, IT
IS STILL THERE.
LET IT STAY.
I THINK TECHNOLOGY, YOU'RE
ALREADY SEEING DOCTORS TO
BASICALLY FACETIME AND SKYPE
VISITS.
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM IF WE LET IT.
>> Jedidiah: COMPASSION IS THE
KEY, YOU'RE RIGHT.
THEY TWIST THAT WORD, THE LEFT
TWIST THE WORD COMPASSION.
IT'S NOT COMPASSIONATE TO HAVE
HUGH MILITARY IN CRISIS AND THE
BORDER AND RISING HEALTH CARE.
THEY CAN'T KEEP THEIR PLAN OR
THEIR DOCTOR.
GOVERNMENT RUN HEALTH CARE IS
NOT COMPASSIONATE.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE FLEE THOSE
COUNTRIES.
>> Juan: SO PEOPLE SUFFERING
FROM THE OPIOID CRISIS AND CAN'T
AFFORD TO GET CARE OR ATTENTION,
IT'S COMPASSIONATE TO KEEP GOING
IN THAT DIRECTION?
IF YOU --
YOU SAID REPUBLICANS LIKE ORDER.
WHAT'S GOING ON IF YOU DO AWAY
WITH OBAMACARE RIGHT NOW?
CHAOS.
COMPETITION.
>> Dana: NOTHING IS CHANGING.